- In a world where cat videos
and memes rule the feeds,
one media company will
rise above the noise,
this is Great Big Story.
- [Director] Okay, Redd, that was great.
Thank you.
- You got it.
- Yeah, that was great.
- Cool.
- [Director] You can stop
speaking like that now though.
- What do you mean?
This is how I always speak.
- [Director] Okay, cut!
(humming)
- My name is Redd Pepper,
I'm a voiceover artist.
In the UK, I voice
hundreds of movie trailers,
"Men in Black," saving the Earth
from the scum of the universe.
"Blair Witch Project," "Armageddon,"
"Space Jam," "Mr. Bean's Holiday,"
so many, I forget half of
them, to be honest with you.
I started doing television adverts,
animations, audio books, I do
a lot of video games as well
and a lot of them are sound effects,
a goose in the background.
(donkey braying)
(roaring)
Mr. Bean.
When I first started doing movie trailers,
that was fun:
one man, coming soon to a cinema near you.
Sometimes I do romantic
movies . . . in a sleepy town;
sometimes I'm doing horror
. . . don't answer the door!
You've got to use your voice;
you've got to raise it sometimes;
and you've gotta take it to the depths.
Very occasionally I get recognized,
but generally no, but the
time I do get recognized,
the phone goes off on
the train, guaranteed.
Hello, and people look up
from behind the newspapers.
The way I got into being a voice
artist was kind of strange,
I used to drive trains on
the London Underground;
one morning I was making my announcements,
all stations to Harrow, mind the doors.
A television executive was
a passenger on my train;
he got off at the next stop,
ran up to my cab, we exchanged details;
and the rest is history.
I've had some strange
experiences as a voice artist,
I was doing a trailer for
"Jurassic Park, The Lost World,"
Steven Spielberg movie and, kindly,
they chose me to do the voice in the UK.
Something is coming,
something big!
And as I said that, a voice
in my headphones said,
"Wow, that's a great voice!"
And I didn't recognize
it was Steven Spielberg,
he was listening in from
the States into London.
Well I swore, I said, who
the (expletive) is that?
Everybody went crazy in the studio,
"Shh, shh, no, it's Spielberg on the set!"
I appreciate what I do;
I'm still meticulous about what I do;
I'm still proud of what I do.
I really don't look at it as a job.
I'm having fun. It really is a cool job;
it's gotta be up there
with one of the coolest
jobs on the planet.
Right, you got it?
Cool, I'm out of here.
Oh, that's a wrap.